Okay, so here is the Python documentation, and if I scroll
down, I can find the os module. Let me click on it.
And in here, we can find all o the OS related functions that we used. So here
is os.change directory, and here is os.getcwd, or
get current working directory. Let me scroll down some
more. And if I do that I find os.listdir, which lists all of the files within a
given directory and on scrolling down even further, I
find os.rename. By the way, I want to make a
quick note here that even though we don't know how
functions like rename really work behind the scenes. We can
read their documentation and use them just fine. This hiding
of detail behind documentation, in computer science, is called abstraction.